news of Kathie Lee's Today Show
departure is still making waves in New
York as the search to fill that seat
right next to Hoda Kotb continues as
Kathie Lee leaves it to Hoda to decide
her replacement
yesterday in Manhattan the Today Show
crew toasted her at their holiday party
Jenna Bush Hager was seen raising a
glass just as ETS confirmed she's the
frontrunner to replace Kathie Lee seem
that way to you all to the sometimes
fourth hour fill-in is a natural choice
because she's already opened up so much
of her life to the show's audiences will
miss anybody but he's in a better place
she just shared her grief morning late
grandfather President George HW Bush
seven months after losing her
tough-as-nails Gani
Barbara there was something bad I
pointed out to you the 37 year old mom
of two famously interviewed the former
first lady for her NBC show reflecting
on a time when Jenna and twin sister
Barbara were seen as wild child first
daughter's I stood up for you when you
stuck your tongue out of all the breasts
because you've been wanting to do that
for years every America knows Jenna's
road to today not exactly a direct one
in 2006 two years after leaving the
White House the college grad became a
teacher's aide several months later she
worked with UNICEF she was shy during
her first et interview at their gala and
then novice at red carpets it can be a
little intimidating yes in oh seven
general the first of several books
including two with mom Laura she edit it
all the way through and it was a lot of
fun to work you know with her then in oh
nine she made her first today appearance
NBC later hired her shelling out a
reported five hundred thousand dollars a
year
The Morning Show got several Bush family
interviews you learned something from
that
yeah I don't pain your wife and Jenna
became NBC's own first daughter
The Today Show it's like a family we
love you we love you thank you for being
with us
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]